بخفه وسرعه ورشاقه يصل الطعام الى طاولتكم
بهذه الطريقه الفريده نادلون غير عاديين
يتنقلون من طاوله لاخرى في هذا المطعم حيث
استبدلوا احذيتهم العاديه باحذيه تزلج
اثناء قيامهم بعملهم
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
[موسيقى]
هنا في المدينه
يقع مطعم يازهو هذا المطعم فريد من نوعه
فهو لا يوظفون ديلين عاديين وانما اشخاصا
ذوي خبره في ارقى المطاعم ومتزلجين بارعين
في الوقت نفسه نادل يرتدي ملابس انيقه
ويحمل مجموعه من الاطباق يتزلج بها بسرعه
كبيره ليوصلك الطعام لطاولتك الناتج هنا
محترف للغايه لدرجه انه يحافظ على توازنه
رغم حمله الثقيل كما انه بارع في المناوره
ويستطيع تفادي حوادث الاصطدام رغم سرعته
الفائقه في مطعم يعج بالطاولات والزبائن
ان ديلون هنا اظهر مهارتهم الرائعه في
التزلج السريع اثناء تقديم الطعام وقالوا
ان خدمه العملاء اثناء التزلج تمثل تحديا
بالنسبه لهم لانهم يحتاجون الى القوه
ومهارات التوازن
لا شيء
اكد ان الموظفين يخدعون لتدريبات صارمه
على التزلج بالاطباق لعده اشهر قبل ان
يكونوا مستعدين لخدمه العملاء مؤكدا ان
بعض النادلين يمكنهم الوصول الى مسافه 15
مترا في الثانيه بسرعه 54 كيلومترا في
الساعه الملك جاءته هذه الفكره المبتكره
عام 2009 لجذب اكثر عدد من السياح
والوافدين الى المطعم
موضوع سلامه الناديين والعملاء فاكد صاحب
المطعم انه منذ افتتاحه لم يصاب اي نادي
او عامل باي اذى
[موسيقى]
شاركونا ارائكم هل تودون تجربه الطعام في
مطعم كهذا